Knight Lautrec looks out for himself.
If we are to judge him, then we should count our own sins first.
You, who invades for humanity.
You, who kills, simply because something is in your way,
or because they have something important to you.
Helm of Lautrec the Embraced, representing the goddess Fina's love.
During his solitude, he forsook everything,
for he believed in the goddess' love for him.
Ring of Favor and Protection, granted by Fina, known in legend to possess fateful beauty.
The ring breaks, if ever removed.
Armor of Lautrec the Embraced, representing the goddess Fina's love.
The goddess' arms wrap around it, as if to embrace the wearer.
The goddess Fina seems more sinister than you'd expect from a goddess of love.
She appears to a man who has forsaken everything, who will commit atrocities to serve
Her ring of protection breaks if you abandon her.
The armor wraps its arms around you, clinging to the wearer.
Is it a reminder of her love,
or to remind you, that you are hers?
We know her love is fateful
If you're hers, you are well and truly a part of her design.
Whatever goal she has, are your's as well.
So did Fina really love him, deeply and personally?
It's possible.
Interactions between the gods and the humans are quite common.
It's also possible that the man is simply within a religious delusion.
We first encounter Knight Lautrec in a cell within the undead Church.
Why a Church has a cell is a story in and of itself,
as is the story of how Lautrec came to be trapped there.
It could have something to do with the Firekeeper soul down below,
or perhaps Oswald the Pardoner.
Maybe both.
For if anyone is drenched in sin it's Lautrec.
And his desire for more humanity is clear
Even Patches speaks of it.
It comes are no surprise then that Lautrec sets his sight on a harmless Firekeeper.
Firekeeper's are corporeal manifestations of the bonfires they keep.
Their souls are a draw for humanity offered to the bonfire.
And as such their souls are gnawed by infinite humanity.
It's clear that this isn't a fate that the Firekeeper enjoys.
Since she expresses that she wishes for the curse of the undead to be lifted
So that she may die as a human.
Her tongue was cut out so she could not complain.
And her bloodstained skirt implies she was maimed so that she may not escape.
Yet, despite this she expresses a desire to fulfill her fate as a Firekeeper.
To a man who desires humanity,
whether for his goddess or for himself.
A Firekeepers soul is quite a prize.
Lautrec escapes with the Firekeeper's soul,
whether he desires it for himself as a trophy or for his goddess is unclear.
Yet, you and many other parallel Undead, track him down
and invade his world.
"So,
here we go again.
How many times will these lambs rush to slaughter?"
"Lets get it over with!"
This is the end of Knight Lautrec.
Whatever his designs were, whatever the goddess wanted
It died with him.
So, is it worth restoring the Firekeeper?
Or will you give in to the same temptations as Lautrec?
Who wants to go Hollow, after all?